the other big story that came out today
was give you soft have kind of got
themselves into a little bit of a
situation with a it's a bit of a
controversial basically it sucked in why
are there no playable lady assassins and
Assassin's Creed unity so this is like
at the full player game like we saw all
the sweet French Revolution Batlin
taking people out assassinating there's
mean the same thing but there was no
chicks and obviously Assassin's Creed
has done pretty well with NPCs in the
past but no playable females and Ubisoft
have said this is kind of down to two
reasons one of the reasons is because
you are supposed to be playing as honor
I mean the the iterations of the lead
character and his gear and his skill
sets and the other main part was that
they said given the amount of time it
was gonna take to have to read your
animations to have to make costumes for
a female character they said it was
gonna double their production time I
mean actually that's interesting because
what's happened now yeah the latest
update to this is that an ex-employee of
Ubisoft who a fact and a former
Assassin's Creed designer John Cooper as
come I said you know that's that's not
really true yeah in his opinion anyway
so basically what he said is in my
educated opinion i would estimate this
to be a day or twos work not replacement
of 8,000 animations I thought that was a
tweety Center and he also said her man
to find a dollar for every time someone
who be self tried to Bill what's a
little SH star star bill shot I think
bullsháá cool shot me an animation tag
yeah yeah so I mean but you know he's
the scrum told ex-employee probably is
this sure the point is still valid
though right I mean I mean it Scott it's
kind of like you gotta get it like I get
that it's it's the story of on oh and
and that's how it is and if there's a
good reason why it ties into the fact
that it kind of needs to be male
protagonist whatever like more power to
you don't put in I don't really agree
with putting in females for the sake of
putting in females but at the same time
I think it is important to have like
playable female characters and if it
isn't connected to story now I would
love to see a female assassin in Union
yeah I mean especially considering
I was like I was looking through the
four of them almost like come on come on
and then wasn't considering this is like
how many assassins creed games we had
not so many don't they're like every
year and you know something oh they're
still doing great still very popular but
it doesn't seem to me that I've not
heard a good reason for not doing it I'm
again like you I don't think we should
want to get into a situation where every
developers have an ax justify their
choice of a male leads yeah that'd be
ridiculous but it would be refreshing to
have you know to have a specially in
coop like that's sad for me here we are
corpsal were playing together by being
who you want to be absolutely absolutely
that's what it is yeah I mean they did a
great job with the liberation Vedas
protagonist was female and that was
super cool so hopefully we'll see you be
self to bring you know something else
out of the bag or at least continue this
conversation and kind of go over yeah
well we kind of want and the game is
talk to the devs and we don't figure it
out and that's great but thank you for
joining me again no problem anytime you
have more live show things going on
we'll be here for years um so be sure
you stay chained we've got a whole other
day of e3 things tomorrow and some
goodies for the rest of the afternoon so
we will catch you again soon
you